vorrei parlarvi di futuro in particolare
di un futuro non troppo lontano
qualcosa che sta accadendo e che
continuerà a trasformare a cambiare la
nostra vita
vorrei iniziare però dandovi alcune
motivazioni
una di queste è il fatto che in questo
futuro in questo scenario mancherà la
forza lavoro
si sente spesso parlare di
disoccupazione invece il racconto
qualcosa di diverso vi racconto di un
futuro dove non ci saranno abbastanza
braccia per fare tutte quelle cose alle
quali siamo abituati tutti costruire
tutti quegli oggetti che ci fa comodo
dopotutto avere il motivo per cui questo
succederà è semplicissimo
la popolazione invecchia le statistiche
le conosciamo tutti per l'italia si
sente spesso parlare di giappone invece
noi sappiamo possiamo andare a vedere i
numeri è scoprire che anche negli stati
uniti un paese che tutto sommato anche
un'immigrazione notevole un certo punto
ci si troverà con una popolazione che
avrà il 20 per cento di persone oltre 65
anni
questo rappresenta 70 milioni di anziani
sono numeri enormi la stessa dicevo se
andiamo a vedere poi cosa succede nel
resto del mondo scopriamo che la stessa
cosa succede in india in cina paesi dove
fino a qualche giorno fa ci saremmo
aspettati di trovare invece un sacco di
una popolazione in crescita un sacco di
persone giovani
in realtà affronteranno lo stesso
problema i numeri presi dal database
delle nazioni unite ci dicono ci
raccontano esattamente questa storia
quindi uno scenario di un futuro un po
particolare dove tutto sommato ci potrà
fare
comodo avere una mano e che mano ci
serve bene qualche anno fa nel 2008 bill
gates scriveva su santifica american che
ci sarebbe oggi lui si aspettava di
vedere in questo ipotetico futuro la
nascita del personal robot dove per
personal robot non intendeva
l'aspirapolvere che forse abbiamo tutti
al giorno d'oggi la spara polvere che va
da solo ma intendeva invece una forza
lavoro di assistenti robotizzati che ci
avrebbe aiutato il lui parla di personal
robot è un po come immaginiamo la
transizione che avvenuta tra il personal
computer e dal computer se volete da me
in frame industriali al personal
computer quindi la computazione per
tutti e qui lui immaginava l'industria
il futuro avrebbe visto invece la
robotica per tutti
se questo stia succedendo meno non lo so
posso darvi delle indicazioni una di
queste indicazioni viene da presepio
google che nel 2013 ha fatto incetta di
ditte start up che si occupano di
robotica di intelligenza artificiale
ora le messe chiuse da qualche parte
nella silicon valley stanno facendo
qualcosa sicuramente nella direzione
della robotica ed è probabile che anche
stiano lavorando su quella che è la
robotica domestica il non c'è solo
google se voi andate a vedere cosa sta
succedendo soprattutto negli stati uniti
toyota investe un miliardo di dollari
per creare un laboratorio dove si fa a
robotica intelligenza artificiale
facebook è andata andavano in giro
zuckerberg tempo fa a tra virgolette
comprare i miei colleghi che si occupano
di apprendimento automatico quindi tutta
una serie di ditte ed imprese che se
volete non sono tradizionalmente nella
robotica in realtà hanno iniziato a fare
delle cose molto nella direzione della
robotica
io penso che questa cosa prima o poi ci
capita tra
al collo nel senso che non è un
movimento fermabile come diceva yogi
berra che era un giocatore di baseball a
cui piaceva rilasciare delle interviste
molto particolari
se ti trovi davanti una biforcazione
prendila e succederà la stessa cosa noi
ci troviamo di fronte alla robotica
dovremo per forza farcela andare bene
allora noi abbiamo iniziato a
attrezzarci abbiamo immaginato anche noi
uno scenario di questo tipo
questo è chiaramente un film da
fantascienza anche recente anche
piuttosto simpatico però è veramente
quello che vorremmo fare come
ricercatori
io faccio ricerca e mi piacerebbe che i
risultati la mia ricerca avessero
un'applicazione di questo tipo quindi un
robot che interagisce con noi che in
grado di fare delle cose utili per noi
tornando a quello che dicevamo prima
manca se volete la forza lavoro perché
no trovarla trovare un aiuto nella
robotica
se dovesse andar male il robot mi fa le
cose in casa e io posso lavorare più
tranquillamente non uso il mio tempo per
fare tutto sommato dei compiti piuttosto
semplici che possono essere
probabilmente automatizzati
noi crediamo che questo sarà il nostro
robot personale noi a noi piace
chiamarlo l'umanoide personale perché
c'è qualcosa di più
io non voglio una macchina basta io
vorrei anche una macchina che
interagisse con me in maniera molto
naturale è importante perché tutto
sommato se mi devo mettere un oggetto in
casa voi preferite comprare quello bello
ben disegnato con un design accattivante
oppure comprare semplicemente una
scatola che fa lo stesso lavoro di
solito ci piace e metterci in casa cose
più belle e noi questo lavoro lo stiamo
facendo quello che vedete in questa
immagine
il nostro piccolo robot umanoide quello
sul quale noi vestiamo ad esempio gli
algoritmi di intelligenza artificiale e
qui nasce un problema perché
sfortunatamente nonostante tutti questi
investimenti soprattutto negli stati
uniti
l'intelligenza artificiale non è pronta
e non è pronta e io non so quando
arriverà
posso darvi delle indicazioni ma sono
così molto generiche per vedere i future
difficilissimo
l'automobile che è quello che si vede in
questo grafico ci ho messo circa 90 anni
ad arrivare al più o meno al cento per
cento delle famiglie americane il
telefono cellulare censi solo 15 preso
questi due esempi perché i 90 anni
dell'automobile rappresentano la
meccanica un oggetto che si muove quindi
molto complicato mentre il cellulare
tutto sommato rappresenta l'intelligenza
del software è possibile che la robotica
in realtà arrivi in qualcosa che sta un
po nel mezzo tra i 90 anni e 15 anni
magari 25 quindi succederà con tempi di
quest'ordine di grandezza però dicevo
dell'intelligenza artificiale perché
questo rimane un problema questi 25 anni
ci devono aiutare in realtà a colmare lo
spazio che c'è tra quello che riusciamo
a fare tecnicamente è quello che ci
aspettiamo che queste macchine facciano
perché altrimenti sarebbero un
banalissimo fallimento commerciale
se non fanno quello che mi serve la cosa
non funziona e allora per fortuna
qualche nostro collega neuroscienziato
ci ha dato una mano ciao a te una mano
iniziando a studiare l'interazione tra
due persone questo si chiama
neuroscienza sociale a volte questo è un
esempio di alcuni esperimenti che sono
stati fatti è stato scoperto di fatto
che io riesco a misurare quando una
persona sta osservando un'azione fatta
da un'altra persona oppure quando vede
semplicemente gli stessi oggetti che si
muovono ma non c'è l'altra persona che
li muove
come se si muovessero per magia cambiano
ad esempio il modo in cui io muovo gli
occhi guardo in maniera molto speciale
se sto osservando un'altra persona e
questo perché è importante noi abbiamo
detto ma il risultato interessante ci
sembra interessante
mettiamo due persone a lavorare insieme
una di queste persone può essere
misurata posso misurare gli occhi
possono misurare la risposta del
cervello attraverso
l'elettroencefalogramma per esempio
posso usare una termocamera misurare le
risposte emotive
beh cosa me ne faccio di questa cosa
alla fine io sono un robotico infatti
che faccio ci metto il robot
quindi io misuro l'interazione tra una
persona e il robot e quindi cosa posso
fare in più pezzi metto a confronto
personale uomo e quello che succede è
che posso raffinare il modo in cui si
comporta il robot fintanto che non viene
percepito dall osservatore come un'altra
persona
chiaramente sarà sempre un robot fatto
di metallo di plastica però quello che
in qualche modo farà scaturire
nell'osservatore una sensazione di
empatia verso la macchina e questo io
posso testarlo anche scomodando il
signor touring che ciò era detto se io
voglio testare un intelligenza
artificiale quello che faccio a
confronto con un essere umano senza dare
indicazioni a chi osserva se sia uomo
macchina
quello che sta interagendo con me io
posso rifare la stessa cosa e quindi
alla fine ottengo una bella macchina che
funziona in qualche modo o fa scaturire
in me
esattamente quello che avrei nel caso
che ci sia all'interazione con altro
essere umano questo è un esempio di
movimento di che abbiamo studiato il
risultato sono di fatto quello che
vediamo qui cioè che vedete quei puntini
crocette segnetti stanno tutti su una
linea che sta a 45 gradi questo vuol
dire che per tutta una serie di
movimenti uomo e macchina non sono
distinguibili chiaramente vedo che c'è
una macchina davanti a me però nel modo
in cui si muove
non riesco a capire o in maniera
implicita penso che questa macchina
avendo in una maniera quasi umana quello
che vedete qua adesso è esattamente una
serie di questi elementi di
comportamento della macchina che la
fanno sembrare un pochino più vicina
all'uomo può fare dei gesti può guardare
l'altra persona quindi porge lo sguardo
porge la mano ci dà un'idea di cosa
intende fare in questa interazione per
esempio non c'è del parlato non c'è
l'interazione vocale e tutto implicito è
tutto fatto nel modo in cui grazie al
modo in cui la macchina si muove questo
è importante perché immaginate appunto
di dover vivere tutti i giorni con un
oggetto di questo tipo e quindi quello
che vi sto dicendo che ci piacerebbe che
il futuro prossimo le macchine fossero
costruite in questo modo e questo magari
per un po ci farà andar bene anche un
intelligenza artificiale non troppo
sviluppata per finire vi scomoderei
asimov il grande isaac asimov scrittore
di tanti libri di fantascienza sulla
robotica che in un passaggio del libro
ai robot descriveva questa scenetta due
persone parlano uno chiede all'altro
quanti anni hai l'altro risponde 32 e il
primo dice ah ma allora non è né
conosciuto un mondo senza i robot
questo per dire ma quando sento questa
frase mi viene in mente mio figlio che
ha 11 anni non ha mai conosciuto il
mondo senza computer
esattamente come diceva il bill gates
passiamo dal computer al personal
computer avremo anche il personal
humanoid grazie